Prismässigt är vi inte alltid så mycket dyrare än vad vi hittar i butik.
Om man då som kum kan få bättre kvalitet eller ett dykvärdigt pris och får det hem till dörren så är det för många en no brainer.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har reda i en bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tuggiga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag ser det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Anton Karlsson som är från Vasafiskerian och det här är ju ett extremt udda, vill jag säga, fast man får väl säga unikt på det snälla sättet koncept.
De säljer skaldjur på nätet, det har jag nog aldrig sett innan.
Tjena Anton och välkommen till podden.
Det här är en skumaffärsidé.
Ja, det får man kanske lov att säga, det är många som reagerar så, och tack så jättemycket för att det får man.
Det är jättekul.
Ja, vi kanske också ska säga att ni har ju gått, med tanke på att man tänker att det är en lite urda idé, så har ni ju gått fantastiskt bra.
Hur ser siffrorna ut här för första, vad blir det i tre åren kanske, två och ett halvt?
Ja men precis, vi grundades ju i mars 2023, och då omsättade vi 3,7 första året, och gjorde ett positivt resultat.
Under 2024 så växte vi till knappt 20 miljoner i omsättning, med fortsatt positivt resultat.
Och nu under 2025 så vi siktar mot 50-60 miljoner i omsättning.
Så att ställa målman, vi tror på det.
Och ja, det är en kul resa hittills.
Ja det är en sjuk utvecklingskurva på någonting som ändå är, det kanske är just för att det är unikt, men vi ska inte gå in i det riktigt än, utan kan du inte bara ta oss tillbaka.
För de flesta som startar e-handelsbolag, tänker ju att jag ska sälja klockor eller smink eller kläder.
Kan du inte berätta när ni satt runt bordet där, för ni är några grunder tillsammans, kan du inte berätta hur det där gick till och även hur ni fick igång hela setupen.
För det där måste ju skickas i ett visst klimat.
Alltså bara ge mig hela grunden liksom.
Ja precis, det finns ju sina utmaningar i det.
Jag har grunnit med mina två kollegor då Simon och Mikael, som är ansvaret för de logistiska bitarna.
Jag, min kunskap ligger framförallt i handel-
och marknadsföring, allt det digitala helt enkelt.
Mikael och Simon har en historia inom fiskvilsbranschen, som är att man åker runt med fiskbilar och knackar dörr, lite som hemglas om man känner till det.
Sen så är min bakgrund inom growth marketing, digital marknadsföring i handel.
Vi kom då i kontakt med varandra för två tre år sedan.
På den vägen föddes liksom...
Ni kom i kontakt, ni var inte polare sedan innan?
Nej, Mikael och Simon är barnomsvänner.
Jag är utomstående i det här fallet då.
Så vi har känt varandra i några år.
Kan du inte ge mig berättelsen där?
Hur gick det till när ni hade det här snacket första gången?
Ja, det var ganska naturligt för att jag har dels haft en bakgrund inom jobbat på en byrå tidigare och konsultat en del inom listbranschen och såg vissa möjligheter att starta någonting i e-gipen.
På samma sätt hade Simon och Mikael tänkt så här att man borde kunna sälja det här via e-handel.
Och helt ärligt så, av en helt slump så kom vi i kontakt med varandra och började spåna idéer och det tog sin tid liksom att komma fram till att vi faktiskt skulle göra det men på den vägen var det.
Ja och sen ni startar en liten hemsida, lägger upp räkor och det är ändå en viss set-up som behövs i detta, ni behöver väl lite kylrum eller skickar ni direkt från leverantörer eller när ni ringde skänker och sa att vi tänkte skicka frysvar.
Alltså fan ge mig liksom det krångliga här nu.
Ja men det är alltså det här, jag har ju ett hus som har Sinon och Mikael här som är betydligt bättre med det logistiska.
För där har vi sina utmaningar där.
Vi har ju självklart ett lager med frysutrymmen så att vi kan hantera varorna.
Allting är fryst eller?
Ja jag skulle säga 90-95% är.
Inte rom kanske?
Jo men faktiskt.
Det är fryst så att i vissa fall säljer vi färska varor.
Men hade vi bara sålt färsk varor då hade det varit en totalmorgon.
Särskilt när man säljer fysisk valor, då blir det väldigt svårt.
Så det är nästan en förutsättning då att man säljer fryst.
Och sen så samarbetar vi med en leverantör då som hanterar kyl-
och frystransporter.
Så vi når i princip 90% av alla adresser i Sverige.
Jag köper det och kunden som kommer till er, nu äter väl inte jag jättemycket kräftor liksom, men jag spontant går ut från affären och så går man in i fiskbilen då, eller det lilla fiskståndet eller vad man ska kalla det.
Och så är det ju där man handlar.
Jag har aldrig tänkt att jag skulle gå in och söka på det och köpa hem.
Jag har aldrig ens haft den tankeprocessen egentligen.
Hur kom ni ut till folk?
Hur började ni i synas?
Och vilka ära kunder?
Vem är det som köper på det sättet?
Vi har en ganska bred målgrupp, men jag skulle säga att majoriteten är lite äldre och folk med relativt god ekonomi ofta vill äga det.
Men det är familjer, det kan vara hälso-
och medvetna personer som vill äta hälsosam fysiskalier.
Det är också matelskare eller sådana som verkligen vill ha kvalitet på sina varor.
För det är något som vi självklart är partiska här om.
Men vi hävdar ganska starkt att det vi säljer är nästan alltid bättre än vad du kan hitta i butik.
Och frågor av våra kunder så håller nästan alla med där.
Varför är det bättre än i butik?
Vad är skillnaden på produkten?
Dels är det att när du friskfryser så får du högre bevaras näringsmängder med.
Det är ofta ett fastare, finare kött.
Om du jämför till exempel vatteninnehåll i vår fisk med det där du får i butik så har det klar skillnad.
Det du köper i butik kan ofta ligga i flera dagar.
I reger så du kommer att märka skillnad om du äter det som du köper från oss.
Men så är det klart, vi är fattiga.
Men alla får sin loa, så får ni se.
Men menar du att det som är i fryzdisken på en vanlig affär hanteras inte på samma sätt då riktigt?
Eller menar du det som man köper där det har tinats upp i kylskåp?
Jag menar att det som du köper i fiskdisken är ju något som har legat, det har ju varit fräskt i flera dagar.
Det som vi säljer brytses direkt på båten, direkt efter fast.
Och det gör skillnad för dels näringsmängden, men också texturen i själva köttet.
Men okej, så någonstans matkonosörer, folk som kan uppskatta godheten i er produkt.
Men är det inte krångligt med, mat på nätet har ju inte gått asbra i Sverige, men skaldjur blir nästan ännu mer nischat.
Ska man vara hemma och ta emot det?
Är inte det bara ett mick typ?
Nej jag får säga att det inte är det.
Vem äter inte fyskoskaldjur?
Det gör nästan alla.
Är du praktisk?
Vart bor du?
Ja, kanske.
Men jag tror att många gör det och det ser vi också att många gör.
Sen är det ju så att fler och fler uppskattar den här upplevelsen att få ett fint paket med fin mat hem till dörren.
Det är smidigt, det blir lite som julafton när man får ett paket här med väldigt fina råvaror.
Det är något som underlättar i vardagen, som många familjer köper där, många äldre som inte vill behöva ta sig till butiken och handla så ofta.
Vi ser ganska många olika typer av kran nu.
Hur ser supply-kedjan ut?
Nu har ni växt ganska snabbt, eller väldigt snabbt får man säga.
Hur sker era inköp?
Hur planerat behöver inköpen vara kontra outbound?
Sker era inköp på prenumeration ibland?
Eller är det att folk köper när de vill?
Eller bara ta mig med i skalningen uppåt?
Jag är lite nyfiken på den.
Hur många fristiskar har ni på lagret?
Hur länge klarar ni er?
Alltså, till stor del baseras det på efterfrågan.
Och vi kan ofta sälja en större del av våra inköp innan vi behöver betala vår leverantör, vilket såklart skapar en relativt stark cash conversion cycle för oss.
Sen så är det ju såklart att nu har vi växt väldigt snabbt här och det skapar ju sina utmaningar i inköpen för det är svårt att prognostisera vad vi kommer sälja.
Men hittills har det gått bra.
Och där är ju framförallt min kollega Simon som sitter och roddar med inköpen som gör det på ett strålande sätt.
Men hur länge har ni grejer på lager i snitt?
Det beror på vilken produkta.
Men jag skulle säga att våra storesäljare säljs snabbt.
Det handlar om veckor innan det är sålt.
Och är det någonsin problem att få in grejer?
Blir det slutprodukter i räkor?
Jag bara säger räker för att det är typ det alla fattar.
Vissa produkter är så att man väntar på det nyfisket.
Sen finns det till exempel att man tar Karlikslövgrond, där är det en viss kvot på hur mycket som får fiskas varje år.
Så det är klart att det inte finns sådana utmaningar.
Men hittills har vi klarat av det bra.
Och hur sker?
En av fördelen med att sälja produkter är ju att priset inte fluktererar så mycket.
Men min tanke är att era inköpspriser kan flukterera ganska mycket.
Är det bara en fördom eller funkar det så?
Så kan det vara, absolut.
Det är klart att det påverkar våra utpriser mot kunden.
Sen agerar vi i en marknad där alla våra andra konkurrenter har någonstans liknande inköpspriser.
Där får man anpassa utifrån konkurrenssituationen.
Men man bulkar inte upp inköpspriser.
Frysvaror kan väl ändå ligga ett tag.
Så det är inte så att man kan köpa på sig 900 ton kräftar när det är högsäsong och sen bara låta det ligga under året.
Det är inte så ni jobbar.
Nej, vi kan jobba så med vissa produkter.
Vissa produkter kan vi boka i stora mängder.
Där vi liksom kan köpa in stora mängder så att vi har det under en lång period.
Och det är historiskt tack vare att det är frysvaror som vi jobbar med.
Sen så är det att vi har goda relationer med våra leverantörer.
Det är en väldigt viktig del i det här.
Så att det möjliggör att vi kan säkerställa att vi har produkter på lagen.
Vad sa du att Gunnar Grunda kom så här, Simon och?
Mikael.
Simon är inköpsnissen här?
Simon är inköpsnissen, precis.
Mikael är logistiknissen.
Simon är han den trevliga i bolaget?
Du vet, snackisen.
Det kanske man kan säga.
Man wheelar och dealerar lite och snackar.
Är det så fiskinköp fungerar?
Eller är det fasta spottpriser?
Eller är det liksom, om man är bra polare med fiskeriet eller vad man kallar det, hur funkar liksom prinsinköpssättningen i era branscher?
Det är klart att relationer är en del i det hela.
Där har Simon starka relationer med många leverantörer.
Sedan handlar det om volymer såklart.
Alltså om vi kommer att köpa ett ton räkor kontra tio ton, så är det ju skillnad i vilket insåldspris vi får.
Där måste vi anpassa likviditeten utifrån där, vilket man vill binda i lager såklart.
Så här finns det många tjänster man kan använda för att förenkla det med finansiering av faktur och så.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad av logistik, det kan folk tycka låter skitsfråkigt, men logistik är väldigt spännande.
Ni skickar ju frysta varor, jag bara intalar mig att det är dyrare då, såklart än icke-frysta varor.
Ni skickar ju dessutom ganska små volymer upp till lite större volymer.
Om man nu beställer ett kilo, jag vet inte, har ni en minimum volym på?
Om man vill köpa en burk rom som väger 125 gram, då måste ju frakten bli helt oproportionerligt hög på den.
Hur tar ni betalt mot kund kontra hur ni betalar?
Vi erbjuder oftast frihem-leverans om du handlar över 999 kronor.
Sen så tar vi en fraktavgift under det.
Så det är klart att skulle vi skicka som du sa 250 gram rom till någon utan att ha en avgift, då går inte vår affär ihop riktigt.
Men de flesta av våra kunder handlar betydligt mer än så, så det är inget problem vi har egentligen.
Vad är en snittård här?
Ungefär ett och åtta, någonstans där.
Ett och sex.
Vad motsvarar det i liksom, vad är standard-orden?
Är det tre kräfter, två kilo räker, en torsk och sjögräs?
Jag vet inte.
Ja, nej men de flesta plockar ihop lite av varje.
Det kanske är två tre varor per order i snitt.
Och då hamnar man i regel någonstans där.
Ett och fem, två tusen per order.
Och om vi tar, för du är CMO i bolaget?
På pappret ja.
Ja, vad är du i verkligheten då?
Ja, nej men alltså vi har ju varit i ett litet team.
Ni har ingen vd på er hemsida?
Jag brukar säga så här att så länge jag får beställa så är allting bra.
Det har varit lite så att vi har hållit ett väldigt litet teamsår.
Det har varit egentligen jag, Mikael och Simon som har drivit det här från dag 1.
Vi anställde en fast anställd i höstas.
Det var vår första anställda.
Sedan dess har vi haft Tim anställda på laget.
Vi har inte haft behov av att ha en vd som bestämmer över oss alla tre, utan det har varit gemensamma beslut.
Sedan har vi tydliga ansvarsfördelningar i bolaget.
Där har vi, jag får bestämma allt som sker med handeln.
Vårt marknadsfördelning.
Och Simon får bestämma allt med inköp.
Och Mikael tar hand om allting med logistiken.
Sedan sinkar vi allting och större beslut har vi gemensamt.
Nu i takt med att vi växer såhär så börjar vi ju komma till en punkt där vi förmodligen behöver se över de här bitarna med organisationen och utse en faktiskt vd.
Kommer ni att göra någon sluten omröstning där alla får skriva ett namn på en lapp och sedan när ni öppnar så är det en röst per person så håller ni på så åtta gånger.
Ja precis, ni får se.
Det kanske är så vi får läsa det.
Jag fattar, det är väl så det kanske ofta ser ut och sedan så får någon ta på sig den här rollen och så är allting ungefär som vanligt.
Ja och det där är väl, jag tror faktiskt Simon är vd på papperet.
Så, men vi får se hur det blir i framtiden.
Vad, anledningen till att jag frågade är att du är CMO är, kan du berätta lite hur ni har fått in kunderna till bolaget, både i början kanske när ni startade och hur det ser ut lite idag.
För jag gissar att det är lite olika modeller och att det har utvecklats en aning över tid.
Men ni har gjort en del samarbeten, gissar jag, jag såg att ni hade jobbat med han, jag kommer inte på vad den här heter, men den här kanalen där de åker runt och testar mat till exempel eller liknande.
Jo men precis, vi har gjort en hel del olika samarbeten med influencers och matprofiler som Proinade till exempel.
Så var det ja, just det.
Det här är fantastiskt innehåll och det är ett sätt som vi har fått kunder på, men sen så skulle jag säga att vi har framförallt växt genom betald annonsering.
Det är där vår tillväxt har kommit från dag ett.
Vad är det för betald annonsering och hur ser den annonseringen ut?
Menar du rent grafiskt eller hur man?
Dels undrar jag i vilka kanaler ni hittar kunden och dels undrar jag typ rent grafiskt vad er sälj pitch är.
För jag har aldrig fått upp, jag har aldrig fått upp såhär, hej vill du köpa krabba online?
För mig har jag svårt att se hur den här hooken ser ut.
Så jag är lite nyfiken på hur ni jobbar.
När man pratar med modervöretag och sådant då är jag extremt onyfiken på deras marknadsföring.
Det är liksom logiskt på något sätt, men det här är mycket mer spännande.
Vi har ju framförallt växt igenom Meta och Google Ads.
Kollar man på Meta så handlar det mycket om att skapa ett aptitligt grafiskt innehåll.
Sen så som jag sa förut, de kunder vi vänder oss till, de uppskattar det här med kvalitet på maten.
Att man får det till dörren.
Det är såklart sådana bitar vi försöker trycka på i marknadsföringen, vilket vi ser fungerar.
Kollar man i Google Ads så finns det i regel höga sökpolymer på sökord som torsk, lax, döjron.
Så att folk söker, trots allt efter, de här varorna på nattet.
Jag fattar, ni behöver inte utbilda folk att det här funkar att köpa så, utan de blir bara glada att det finns en nischad aktör som sysslar med detta.
Du säger två olika grejer här.
Du säger dels den kvalitetsgrejen som vi pratade om, men även frakt-sättet.
Men min upplevelse är att frakt-sättet, det här är bekvämt och skämt, det känns mer som ett, det är er affärsmodell eller er transportsätt, snarare än att man går till en butik.
Är det kvaliteten som är er usp?
Är det det som gör att man väljer det?
Och hur visar ni upp det?
Ja, kvaliteten är en viktig del.
Sen så ska man också säga att rent prismässigt så är vi inte alltid så mycket dyrare än vad du hittar i butik.
Det är också en viktig faktor.
Om man då som kund dels kan få bättre kvalitet till ett likvärdigt pris och få det hem till dörren, så är det för många en no-brainer.
I marknadsföringen så handlar det om att visa upp det i formal.
Det skapar alltid lite innehåll som påkundarna har att förstå att det här ser jäkligt gott ut.
Förmedla att det här är något du får hem till dörren och vara tydlig med prissättningen.
Även visa hur många nöjda kunder vi faktiskt har.
Det skapar ju social proof.
Man ser att andra uppskattar våra varor.
Då tänker man att vi också vill testa.
Kan du berätta hur ni började med att nå ut till kunder?
Var det på samma sätt som idag eller har det förändrats över tid?
Till stor del har vår tillväxt varit tack vare betalanonisering.
Det är så vi har dragit in nya kunder.
Det är så vi har stärkt varumärket och sen blir det en snabb as-effekt.
Vi har en stark återkommande grad på våra kunder.
Vi anskaffar kunder på ett lönsatt sätt.
Vi har en skalbar business så det rullar på.
Är ni tre, jobbar ni alla i bolaget idag?
Ja.
Har ni drivit business innan?
Simon och Mikael, de drivit en fiskbilföretag förut.
De har varit i branschen förut.
Jag har gjort diverse projekt.
Började på en byrå som sagt och sen så det är ju en lite olika projekt.
Men framför allt det här om vasafiskbilen.
Märkte ni liksom, så har de upp sitt fiskbilsföretag eller vad man ska säga, eller finns det kvar någon anställd eller märkte ni direkt på att fan det här tog ju fart, nu kör vi.
Simon och Mikael körde det där lite parallellt ett tag.
Och sen så var vi faktiskt här, och sen så gick Vasa in och köpte upp den verksamheten.
Så det är en del i vår tillväxtplan, att vi vill få fler ben att stå på, fler införsäkringar.
Så har det sett ut.
Hur känns det att ni då kommer att ha massa anställda jämfört med den här linjen min, affärsmodellen med e-handel?
Ja men det är kul.
Det är kul att vi växer och har en större organisation.
Att vi faktiskt blir ett stort företag med flera människor, det är något roligt i det också, att man skapar en företagskultur och inte bara sitter tre grunder som jobbar på sida här.
Du berättade här i början innan vi satt oss, du sitter fortfarande hemma och jobbar, ni kör fortfarande den sanna uppstartskulturen.
Ja precis, jag sitter och jobbar i Örebro för tillfället, vi får se hur länge det här blir.
Men i och med att mitt arbete är framförallt digitalt så kan jag i princip göra vart som helst.
Sen så lite annorlunda för Micke och Simon då som hanterar logistiken.
Finns det några konkurrenter som, eller finns det många konkurrenter som jobbar direkt på samma sätt som ni gör?
Alltså med ett sådant nischat utbud rakt mot en slutkonsument.
Det finns många konkurrenter som försöker göra liknande som vi gör.
Det gör vi absolut.
Hur går det fram?
Finns det någon stor bjäss?
Jag skulle säga att vi är störst i branschen nu.
Sen är det klart att det finns både mindre och medelstora.
Men helt ärligt så vi lägger inte stor vikt på våra konkurrenter utan vi har en tydlig vision för vad vi ska göra och vi fokuserar på det.
Kan vi inte prata lite om visionen där?
Ni har rätt kraftiga omsättningstillväxtmål här.
Det är ju kaxigt i sig.
Vilket jag gillar bara så att det tillväxt.
Vad har ni för förhoppningar?
Är det bara att gasa och se vad som händer?
Eller har ni någon sån här masterplan på fem år?
Du måste inte dela den exakt.
Jag bara undrar hur ni tänker.
Vi har en tydlig vision vad vi vill göra med bolaget.
Det tror jag är en styrka i vårt samarbete.
Vi alla har en enad vision och jobbar hårt för att uppnå det.
Som du sa, det är ambitiösa tillväxtmål, men det är ingen tvekan om att vi kan nå det.
Vi kollar på den tillväxt vi har.
De siffror vi har sett nu i år kontra föregående år, så ser det positivt ut.
Sen är vi givetvis av all mjukhet för att externa faktorer kan påverka.
Det kan vara prispåvaror, det kan vara inköpspriser som stiger, sånt som givetvis kan sätta käppar i hjulet.
Men så länge ingenting sånt sker, då kommer det här, då ska vi klara av det.
Ni tre, hur lång tid tog det från att ni träffades där på nåt mystiskt möte för några år sedan och bara insåg att det här var en fin match tills att ni startade bolaget.
Och i och med att det här är två barndomspolare och du som utbörling, hur känns den konstellationen?
Hur sker dialogen mellan er tre?
Hur har ni sett till att det ska funka?
Det hörs vi på telefon alldeles för ofta.
Vi har en väldigt nära dialog så det fungerar väldigt bra.
Simon och Mikael är väldigt bra på att dela med sig vad som sker på sina håll och kanter.
Jag försöker göra min bästa med att dela med mig vad som sker här.
Så hittills har inte det här varit något problem.
Ni har inte haft några större konflikter än?
Nja.
Man får ha konflikter, fan vi har konflikter jämnt.
Ja, när du frågar Simon och Mikael kommer de att säga att Anton är inte den jobbigaste personen att jobba med.
Är det du som är den, vad ska man säga, den krångliga?
Jag är nog den som kanske ställer ganska höga krav på allihopa, och vill att saker och ting sker i ett snabbt tempo.
Det kanske inte alltid är det roligaste att jobba med.
Jag förstår.
Har du blivit värre de senaste åren eller har du tornat ner?
För det kan ju gå åt båda hållen.
Ja, det får fråga Simon och Mikael där.
Har de en egen chatttråd där de liksom delar sina värsta Anton Stories?
Troligtvis, troligtvis.
Är den tillväxt, är den fortfarande lönsam?
Ja, det är den.
Vi har växt lönsam från dag ett och det har varit vårt fokus.
Vi har optimerat för tillväxt med de där lönsamma förhållanden.
Det är ju jävligt fina ord att säga men det är jävligt svårt att göra.
Hur har ni lyckats med det?
Det är det, men där handlar det om att ha koll på siffrorna.
Alltså, vi måste ha koll på utgifterna, hålla fasta kostnader minimalt.
Jag vet exakt vad en ny kön får kosta.
Det handlar liksom om att skruva på siffrorna hela tiden där och det har vi bra koll på.
Det var alldeles för generellt, nej, nej.
Det låter som om du har gått en bra utbildning på handeln.
Vad är det ni är duktiga på?
Vi har haft en väldigt effektiv marknadsföring för oss.
Vi har kunnat skaffa kunder väldigt lansamt och vi har många kunder som återkommer.
Gör man det, då kan vi ha koll på siffrorna och växa lansamt.
Sen så som jag sa, håll ner fasta kostnaderna.
Det är en superkraft om man ska skala.
Om vi kollar på den här återkommande kunden, det är ju en fantastiskt fin...
Dels har ni ganska höga åd i världen för att ha en återkommande kund.
Man kan ju ha återkommande kunder, men jag tänker att ni har en möjlighet i ganska fin regelbundhet och i ganska höga siffror.
Har du någon känsla för, eller klart du har, men vill du dela med dig av hur stor andel återkommande kunder ni har och hur ofta de återkommer?
Kanske inte vi delar med med de exakta siffrorna där, men det är en stor andel, så kan jag säga.
Det är som du säger, vi har ju tacksamma varor för att det är naturligt att man konsumerar sina varor och sen så köper man igen, givet att man är nöjd med varorna, vilket de flesta är.
Så att på så sätt är det ju enkelt för oss att säga att okej vi vill gå plus minus noll på nya kunder och sen så kan vi optimera för det här och bara växa på vår kundbas.
Och sen så vet vi att x procent återkommer.
Då kan vi räkna på vilken lönsamhet vi bör ha.
Hur har ni liksom, vi har ju en period i Sverige när alla käkar skaldjur och jag tänker att det är verkligen en sån här peak-säsong, det måste det vara.
Har ni någon sorts planeringsfunktion bland era gamla återkommande kunder att nu är det snart dags, här är liksom, fyll i vad du vill ha under det datumet som man kan förboka 14 kilo.
Vi kör ibland sådana förbokningserbjudanden.
Det är såklart att vi säljer ofta säsongslådor, det kan vara påsklådor, midsommarlådor, julådor och så vidare.
Och sen så är det ju vissa produkter kommer nyfiska under vissa säsonger och då ligger kunderna på fråget och vill beställa.
Så absolut, det är ett sätt.
Nu ska jag bara säga till alla som lyssnar att nu är de seriösa frågorna slut.
Nu har jag varit seriös länge nog.
Nu tycker jag bara att det här är spännande.
Och du behöver inte svara om du inte vill.
Vad är den bästa produkten, vad säljer ni mest av och hur många ton som säljer ni?
Vi säljer mycket räkor, mycket löjrom, men även mycket fisk, alltså torsk, lax.
Mycket blandat.
Men kollar man till exempel våra lyxräkor som har blivit otroligt hypade, så där har vi sålt över 40 ton i ett runda slänga.
Så det finns såklart vissa produkter som säljer betydligt bättre än andra.
Ofta är det 80-20 i regeln och det stämmer ganska bra.
Har ni några produkter som ni bara, det här tycker vi inte om, varför köper folk detta?
Personligen har jag väl säkert det.
Vilken är den äckligaste produkten ni säljer?
Åh, jag personligen är inte så mycket för friterat, men det är ju förvisso vad många andra gillar, lättlaget och så där.
Så det säljer ganska bra ändå.
Hur är era tanke kring sortimentsberedning?
Ni har en del skumma produkter, ni har till exempel kött, och ni har oliver, och ni har skogshornung med tinjansmak.
Det är ju inte det första tre produkterna jag tänker på när jag går in och kollar räker.
När holkar man ur varumärket?
Vi kryddar med sådana där komplementvaror.
Fogus kommer alltid vara fisk, har ju de kaviar.
Sen så tar vi in lite kött, vi tar in lite delikatesser, lite utifrån säsong.
Men som sagt, det är komplement, det är inte vår huvudsakliga utbud.
Och hur sker, fan det blir ju seriösa frågor ändå, men hur sker uppköpsintaget?
I vilka regioner köper man in den här maten?
Och sker det från massa olika leverantörer?
Eller finns det stora grossister som hanterar sånt här?
Hur funkar den industrin?
Det är väldigt olika.
Det är dels grossister, ibland kommer man ner i källan.
Det kan vara både från utländska aktörer eller från inom Sverige.
Så det är väldigt bland annat.
Men vad kommer liksom, vad är huvudprodukter ifrån?
Vad är standardmarknaden för räker och rum?
Jag kan ingenting och sånt här.
Ja men alltså, Karls Slöjrom, det är ju svenskt.
Det är ju ändå rätt logiskt, men...
Nej men, sen är det väldigt blandat, och det är ju som jag sa för att utsyma och sitta på ett brett kontakt, för att det är med flera olika kontakter som vi varierar vår inköp ifrån.
Så där har vi goda förutsättningar.
Ja, det tar inte slut.
Men skiljer det sig mycket i smakbilden?
Jag tänker om en kund har vant sig vidare, du sa att lyxräkaren här, är den alltid från samma aktör liksom, eller kan den variera och kan det skilja sig i smak beroende på vilket område den har simmat i liksom?
Absolut.
Sånt kan definitivt variera.
Nu alldeles nylig, vi fick in nyfiskade lyxräkor.
Det är klart att det kan påverka smak och kvalitet och så.
Som tur är så har vi haft väldigt bra kvalitet och omdömen på det nya också.
Men det är såklart en utmaning i att man kan aldrig vara säker på att en torsk är lik den andra.
Så, men...
Sitter ni och provsmakar, batcher?
Ja, det gör vi.
Absolut.
Det är en del av jobbet.
Man beställer hem provvören såklart.
Vi vill inte sälja någonting som vi inte kan stå bakom.
Ofta har vi samarbeten med matprofiler och låter dem testa det här som vi säljer också.
Det är såklart om vi säger att det här är jättebra kvalitet så kommer folk att tänka att det är partiska, vilket det är.
Men om vi låter någon tredje part faktiskt fästs det åt så är det lite mer trovärdigt då.
Anton, fan vilket spännande bolag ni har byggt.
Och fan vad fort ni har byggt det.
Sjukt imponerande.
Väldigt roligt att se.
Det ska bli väldigt spännande att se vad ni är om några år.
Ja, nej men tack för det och vi har höga mål och hoppas att alla lyssnare ska känna till oss i framtiden.
Vi vill bli ett allt känt varumärkligt.
Gå in på Vasafiskerian och spana in lite.
Det finns allt från oliver till räkor så att någonting ska vi hitta.
Det ser väldigt fint ut.
Tack så mycket.
Tack.
Är det tre kräfter, två kilo räker, en torsk och sjögräs?
Jag vet inte.